we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here is a
voicemail that came in today um so what
question I'm um I'm assuming you're
probably familiar with the show Real
Time with Bill Maher yes if asked would
you go on and of course thank you yeah a
lot of times we get voicemails like
these would I be willing to appear and
oftentimes Bill Maher is the one that's
mentioned of course I would it would be
huge publicity if I was invited onto the
Bill Maher program you think you get the
10 minute interview now just be one of
the panelists I think if I were invited
on the Bill Maher program and there's no
indication that that's going to happen
as of now although I would love it and
please email them and tweet them and
tell them to invite me I think I would
definitely be on the panel I don't think
at this point my status I'm not Milo you
Napoles you know my logos the ten
minutes sit down with Bill Maher I am
not deserving of that Milo is so famous
that other people decided to pull
themselves off of the show because he
was appearing yeah so of course I would
appear with Bill Maher and I would
encourage people in the audience hey
listen if that's something that's of
interest maybe let's get a little
campaign going to get me on there that
the scope with which that would move the
needle for the David Pakman show is
significant that is a show I've been on
CNN I've been on Fox News it did very
little in terms of bringing audience to
the show and even sometimes it was a
longer appearance like on CNN I was on
for I was the only guest being
interviewed by Aaron Bernal for longer
than I was on Fox News it did barely
anything for our web traffic YouTube
subscribers whatever I think Bill Maher
underpin appearance on Bill Maher would
do a lot yeah especially cuz you think
of CNN is more of a general audience Fox
News viewers aren't gonna tune in to you
after because they're not servitors but
Bill Maher's audience is largely
progressive yeah and I think that that
would actually be huge I think appearing
on the Bill Maher program and the Joe
Rogan program both are formats that
would lend themselves to a lot of new
people coming into the the universe of
the David Pakman show on the bonus show
today America's healthiest and least
healthy states San Francisco is using
robots to drive away the homeless and
people are not happy and we will talk
about human feet
washing up on the Pacific Northwest what
is that all about we will talk about all
of those stories and more on today's
bonus show two ways to get the bonus
show one get a membership at david
pakman.com slash membership to become a
patron for at least five bucks a month
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
and remember way over here now we do
have the 2018 calendars available for
free with membership at david pakman.com
slash calendar 18